I think all of the chemistry and all of the
science
is in service of trying to create aesthetic
beauty in a glass.
When you sip from a glass of well-aged smokey
whiskey,
you can almost taste the years its been sitting
in a barrel.
And that’s what allows distillers to charge
in the thousands of dollars for a top-shelf bottle.
So as the booze sits in a barrel for decades
and decades and decades,
the wood sort of slowly dissolves into it
and, as the polymer structures that make the
wood, wood, slowly fall apart,
they shed all of these precursor chemicals
that turn into different stuff
that tastes really good.
You guys want to hop aboard?
Careful getting on, it is on water.
We took this boat ride deep into this jungle
to talk with Bryan Davis,
one of the co-founders of Lost Spirits Distillery.
He’s part of a community of craft distillers
who have opened up shop in the last ten years,
riding a wave of interest in premium beverages.
So that's actually a little top secret-ish
in terms of exactly what it’s doing.
But it's part of a set of experiments that
are designed around
scaling up the technology we’ve been working
on.
You’ll find a lot of oddities inside of
Davis’ distillery.
Everything from a hypotonic floating carousel
to god like statues
to a dragon skull sitting in a room straight
out of the Island of Doctor Moreau.
But you won’t find rows of oak barrels aging
booze.
That’s because he’s developed an untraditional
way
of making spirits taste like they’ve been
sitting around for decades,
when in fact they’re a mere six days old.
I got to be the first guy to recreate, effectively,
the chemical signature of 15-20 year old bottles
of booze in the laboratory.
Davis, who has won multiple awards for his
product,
invented a reactor that mimics the natural
aging process when booze is left in a barrel.
That's sort of the thing that put us on the
map, and created the lab and the business model.
This time and money-saving technology could transform
the market for aged spirits
by bringing these products within reach of
a larger community of liquor consumers.
Davis took an unconventional path to becoming
a liquor distiller.
He started making his own booze in high school
when he couldn’t get a good enough fake ID.
Built sort of rudimentary still out of crap
from the garage
and made some pretty awful booze.
He eventually went to art school for college
where he studied sculpture
and then went on to design for amusement parks.
That jungle you saw earlier sits in a warehouse
in downtown Los Angeles
and it’s one of the many worlds that Davis
says he’s trying to recreate for drinkers
through their taste buds.
I certainly still think like an artist
and it definitely influences the approach
that I take to what I'm trying to make.
I think all of the chemistry and all of the
science
is in service of trying to create aesthetic
beauty in a glass.
The liquor world has been forbidding to small
distillers since the repeal of prohibition.
To get started in the industry, Davis had
to get creative.
When he arrived in California with his significant
other Joanne Haruta,
who's also his business partner,
they tried to get into the whiskey and rum
business,
but Davis says he needed almost half a million
dollars in backing to produce a three-year-old bottle.
We were utterly broke.
So, we started down the path of figuring out how to go get old boilers
out of apartment buildings in San Francisco on Craigslist for $500.
and we built all the stills out of sheet copper
with a hammer and a torch.
But they still needed warehouses and barrels.
We would just be literally sitting there going,
"Okay, we'll sell our first bottle of booze
when I'm 60,"
And I thought, "Well, I mean, it's only chemistry,
right?
I don't really know anything about chemistry,
but how hard can it be?"
So Davis went on the internet
and started watching YouTube videos of chemistry
classes taught at MIT.
And every time I hit a vocabulary word I didn't
understand, I'd just pause it
then go to Wikipedia and put in the vocabulary
word and then read that.
Then it would typically reference other vocabulary
words that I didn't understand.
You can just sort of tunnel your way down
the rabbit hole
until all of a sudden one day you read a paper
and go,
wow, I understood everything that said, you know?
By 2013, Davis had figured out how to force
the chemical reaction called esterification,
which is the main driving force behind barrel
aging.
You're not like cooking with wood, it's not
like you're flavoring spirits with the barrel,
you're actually triggering a series of downstream
chemical reactions
that change the nature of the product.
But he couldn’t come up with a natural way
to mimic the effects of time
and break the polymer structures in wooden
barrel
that give a well-aged bottle of booze its taste.
One day, while thinking about how he had to
replace the sun damaged wooden deck
attached to his mobile home, he had an epiphany.
So I'm sitting there standing on this old
worn out deck
and the little voice in the back of my head
is saying
you need to put a new coat of paint on the deck.
But it sort of said it in science nerd terms,
right, which was, you know,
"Gee, the sunlight's doing one hell of a number
on the polymers
that are holding the structural integrity
of the wood together on your deck.
You should really put a new coat of paint
on it."
and I sort of got maybe 100 feet away and
then went like, “Huh.”
His idea was that by blasting wood with light
he could speed up the effects of degrading
a barrel’s wood into the alcohol.
So he went to Home Depot and bought every
lighting fixture and bulb he could get his hands on.
And I called my electrician, had him come
over
and we unplugged all the power from everything
on the property
and routed all the electricity into the barn.
And then set up all these different light
fixtures aimed at different jars of booze
with the wood in them.
And then turned them all on ran whole different
giant battery of tests.
He also found that type of wood used in his
process impacts the taste.
One of his current projects is to recreate
rum from the 1860s and 70s
aged in American chestnut barrels.
The problem is that the American chestnut
tree went extinct in 1915.
And so we went to auction and started buying
furniture made out of American chestnut
and bringing it back and slapping it on a
table saw,
buzzing off pieces of it so that you could
extract the usable wood
and toasting and charring it and using it
to try and create the profiles
that you would have got from barrels.
Today, you can find Davis’ liquor in specialty
liquor stores
and he regularly appears at distilling conferences.
The technology is talked about endlessly on
liquor blogs too.
Liquor companies have lobbied for laws that
outline strict definitions
of what you may call certain types of alcohol,
so he’s had to come up with some non-traditional names.
For example, we make, what, for all intents and
purposes,
is a very highly awarded Scotch whiskey
that we call Abomination and we label it as
a heavily peated malt
and I have no idea what that means.
But Davis doesn’t mind the variety.
He dreams of a future in which liquor store
shelves are lined with bottles
that customers don’t recognize.
As a consumer, none of it would make any sense
and you'd have to look it up
and actually understand what you're buying.
If you look at this from an art world's point
of view,
once upon a time sculptures were made of stone
or bronze, paintings were done in oil,
there were two styles of painting that you
could do.
In the case of distilled spirits, we sort
of gradually evolved into that same position
but the industry had the advantage of being
able to consolidate after prohibition.
So instead of having 10,000 small distilleries
across the United States
you suddenly had ten.
And so all that consolidation meant these
guys made basically the same thing
and then, and then ultimately, they wanted
to try to legally enshrine their own monopolies
and so they created laws that said, "Whiskey
must be exactly this."
I sort of view myself as that same antagonist
to those canonistic systems
and have a ball trying to see how many monkey
wrenches I can throw into arguments in the systems
without breaking the laws.